ladies and gentlemen we got him well I
guess is another me my killed is it a
good defense that it was a deep-fried
meme don't make it worse Felix don't
make it worse moving on today is today
where it's all going down luckily I'm
able to shoot this before the pewdiepie
subreddit I know what's gonna happen to
it okay it's not good so I'm shooting
this now just to get out of out of the
way I know we said no more or unoriginal
content but it's now or never and I'm
taking the opportunity I ain't
understand what he's talking about they
keep it that way
okay moving on what is this wait what is
this in support of no meme revolution I
encourage you all to just post picture
of your hey damn it you think you can
outsmart me I'm not even wearing any
headphones right now what are you gonna
do my audience think they're better than
me they think they owe if we don't post
any memes on the pewdiepie sub ready
then he'll have to create his own
content but the memes about not posting
memes are in fact memes oh that's right
everybody I'm level 5000 is moving on to
another great meme here we go for it we
started off strong Jesus is that a
monster I was booming even when I was 17
16 oh I literally just were some Juan
Carlos glasses so we could make out Oh
see hmm man I wish there were more
bodyguards there it would have been so
beautiful Nick missed opportunity meme
correction do it right and do it again
there are no memes here Pierce please
play good old Lego Star Wars AF Detroit
game
it better be Lego Star Wars on the
Nintendo DS oh wow it's a thing be
careful what you wish for meme locked
due to lack of original come on guys I
need you please I'm dying here
alright I need to move past this whole
media thing please give me peeps I beg
you I actually thought this was real for
a second it worked
my fans forced me to do it Wow
see there you go it work now please pose
for me hi Felix today was my teachers
last they are working in my school and
he's amazing teacher at the end of the
lesson we did a debate on what's better
means or gifs gifs memes obviously and
he clapped his hand twice and shouted
meme review and he looked at me and then
said but can you do this well I'm the
story and can you say hi his name Joshua
Hill because apparently is watching this
can we post this and this totally happen
subreddit this definitely happened hi
Joshua
thanks for teaching the 9 year olds of
the world as a 9 year old that's quite
impressive only people are not Peter pie
conceited this is bullying this is
cybernetic bullying I will not stand for
treating people badly online that is one
of the worst things you could possibly
do and I don't understand do you
understand how people feel bad you can't
when the video is in 10 minutes long yet
check out ABS everybody it's out every
single console ever I think you guys are
willing George oh my god it's this love
I saw this one oh my god oh my god
that's beautiful
you know what lost lives on how about
that this gets 5000 uploads no meme here
Pizza oh come on come on why do you hate
me I know I got enough abuse can I not
get some love daddy want some love from
90 oh no wait
just stop it okay just stop the
cyberbullying I don't know for the mama
for Papa formats yet you host love why I
thought it was sucking on her you know
what let's just move on
no meme just me and some ducks those are
some hairy legs for a nine-year-old
maybe the duck is the nine you all might
see I'm not having any means to look at
nine year olds only posting pictures of
Marcy until she hosts love wine the here
it is again you just want to get rid
instead of my chicken we have jacksFilms
hose the wine he does it every single
day okay and I've had enough if we make
my tea I mean PewDiePie can't make me
review anymore because he don't want to
kill his fiancee don't test me buddy
I mean if this is successful we will
have infinite original content you know
what you know what I would be mad but
I'm also proud for the deeper level
thinking this is what I'm trying to
accomplish on this channel for
nine-year-olds to think Elohim or higher
think the extra step the extra mile I'm
crying right now
because I mean fear I really do believe
that boots is underrated despite being
the most popular youtuber he's one of
the most genuine people on this platform
it's really unappreciated is staying
humble and true to himself up to eight
years of making videos I feel like this
is a very nice comment but I feel like
you're not up to speed with what's going
out there okay I am a horrible name err
I post deep fried means like a box not
like a bars okay I don't deserve this
compliment please take it away
give it to someone else that's more
worth just saw this and had to put I've
seen this before
honestly one of the reason I wanted to
play beyond was just to get the meat and
I still don't get them let my Xia hos
Lawai okay fine five hundred thousand
likes - yeah will host the next love
wine and that's a promise but then you
have to keep posting memes deal deal
when are you just being ridiculous since
memes gets down here's the view from my
hike today wow what a great view
everyone smash like who needs memes this
is great this is phenomenal they're lost
in here somewhere if Marcy is subscribed
appears then doesn't it make kids engage
to an I know stop it
get some help no please but hey I need
this video to get to ten minutes somehow
we
my eyes Jesus Christ this Felix guy
should make a YouTube channel he is
really funny this comment gets reposted
on every single might see a video work
that I'm in you're telling me that I
don't post original content
oh we're equally bad here let's face it
we're both skub we're both the lowest
degenerates of the earth posting
PewDiePie means like what are we doing
here
is there not anything better than if we
could be doing Brad hoes Lawai and Puetz
edited No
are we posting pets here now this good
boy is 63 in dog years I've seen this
photo before are you guys reposting Hey
look at Gare you finally have a friend
how about there how can my xia hos love
why
if there are no memes on the subreddit
well as in mars is going to review it
next week why don't we just make it a
mindset related means leave your that's
nice alright we'll have that as an
intern next week thank you
[ __ ] road sir very cool my chair will
be hosting the why in the next episode
this is a faker de coeur
but it's alder true so it's okay nothing
stands in the way of the nine year old
army sky low on the Y Detroit gameplay I
guess you know completely overrun by my
audience here this is not even my
channel anymore they don't even want me
here so I don't know really know what
I'm doing here since everyone agreed to
not pose any means I'm gonna pose this
cute cat great thank you
hashtag throwback I went to the bathroom
and almost had a heart attack I see you
met Jerry hey an army of Jerry's
everybody it's happening hey that's
really cool
it's not a meme but you know I'll take
it thank you very much a finger year
finger you what if everyone just posted
pictures of Mike
I had a rough day okay please having my
SIA hose the wine having dr. Phil host
oh why yes of course this is only the
natural progression dr. Phil if you're
watching it would be my honor
I want Puetz to explain this well you
see this is the first episode of scare
PewDiePie season two and this is the
reason why it actually never got
released
I found poor Wetzel 600 to 500 BC
Etruscan ceramic in a museum today I was
so excited until I remember Felix
already reviewed this meme now I'm
eternally stuck posing beside a dead
mean where is it where is it
why didn't you steal it and give it to
me you don't look 9 it must be her mom I
want it all right dad me more not alone
from that 27
we must upload memes only in Italian sir
pewds will need my SIA help to translate
that why do you do this why do you hate
me so much
well clearly it's time for me to end I'm
clearly just taking the equivalent of a
facebook mean page so you know what fine
you win nine-year-olds but don't come
crying to me
[Music]